voilà ce que dit en substance cette
nouvelle décision dans cette affaire du
mime l'ordonance du 14 décembre 2018
sera complétée des noms de toute
personne justifiant être membre de
l'association mouvement indépendantiste
martiniquais soit depuis 2012 2013 2014
2015 2016 2017
conséquence de cette ordonnance datée
d'hier le 29 janvier plus de 400
personnes pourraient participer à
l'assemblée générale du mime
cela fait autant de votants il suffit
simplement de payer une cotisation avant
l'assemblée générale
et c'est précisément cela que voulait
éviter le groupe de réflexion du
mouvement indépendantiste
il estime que seuls peuvent voter ceux
qui sont à jour de leur cotisation en
2018 les militants officiel pourtant en
décembre dernier ce groupe avait obtenu
gain de cause le tribunal de
fort-de-france autorisés à participer au
vote que 214 personnes dans toute
élection il y a un corps électoral qui
est qui est défini il n'est pas aussi en
tout cas moi je suis dans l'incapacité
de le déterminer aujourd'hui de savoir
qui composent qui sont des adhérents du
mime qui sont ceux qui pourraient voter
à une assemblée générale
j'ai reçu notification de 7 2 7
cette ordonnance modifiant la précédente
hier aux environs de 21 heures pour
qu'on comprenne bien
donc il y a malheureusement
une impossibilité pour nous de
participer à une assemblée générale dans
ses dans ces conditions là l'ordonnancé
rendue hier sera donc contesté par
l'avocat
il estime en outre que qu'il est
difficile en effet de savoir qui est
membre ou pas en raison de l'absence
depuis quelques années d'assemblées
générales
il ne comprend pas les décisions des
juges qui sont toujours rendus à
quelques heures des assemblées générales
c'est l'histoire de rendez vous manqués
le 7 septembre dernier à quelques heures
de l'assemblée générale nous apprenions
qu'une vingtaine de nos membres est
écarté de la liste
aujourd'hui à quelques heures également
de l'assemblée générale nous apprenons
que la liste électorale se trouverait
augmenté de nombre indéfini de
deux personnes oui nous sommes surpris
du timing l'assemblée générale qui
devait se tenir aujourd'hui en fin
d'après-midi a donc été annulée une
nouvelle raquette sera lancée par
l'avocat du groupe de réflexion pour
l'heure pas de date pour une nouvelle
assemblée générale du mime